for me I got to get my poop so to speak
in a square tighten it up so that I'm
super Sue again but how do I do that
these are the two overflow tents and I'm
not going to have people using them for
quite a while so I want to Annex this
one and make it into my physical
Improvement Center the
gym I don't have a big weight set and a
barbell and you know thing just laid
down on and that's that's not the kind
of improvement physical Improvement I'm
looking for what I'm trying to do is as
I age the arthritis is setting in the
range of motion is decreasing the Bears
stay just as damn fast as the moment
they were born and I can't
compete unless I improve slightly where
I'm
at
I'm not looking to be Suzi
Shena I'm not the suminat I'm flexis
soup what I'm looking for is weight not
heavy weights light weights to work my
range of
motion a cone on the runway got in my
way and I went down like a little infant
not getting a candy bar I can't have
fracturing going on and instability
and expect to have a topnotch running
place so I got some rope here got some
police here my body is hurting the pain
that this shoulder whatever is putting
me through it's one more thing and this
caffin of things that's just riotously
making me break down I've got to do my
own form of
therapy
it's time to get myself together and uh
maybe see what I want to
construct I'm approaching 60 at 60 M an
hour I don't have angst about getting
older per se but I can tell you the body
it's not regenerating anymore you're on
the downhill cycle we are all going to
have that epiphany
that says you now
officially have lived more years than
you are going to
live maybe everybody else's road to
health is is paved with good intentions
and and the golden staircase mine rust
grease a little Ingenuity this is just a
piece of pieces of junk an old Rim old
electrical stuff but really simple
you're just forcing your
body to lay
open and stretch all of this is
stretching out the other interesting
thing that I can
do grab it and come up with it grab it
and come up with
it I wanted to add
weight now
there's a lot you can
do and I didn't pay this incredible
price to get it done the Sue gym is
operational this isn't going to fix
everything this is one part the mind the
body the spirit but it's going to take
me from waiting for the next
problem to hell yeah I found a
solution
[Music]